nochmal versuche ich an meine einleitung
immer möglichst tiefgründig und
irgendwie erzählerisch zu gestalten aber
könne man einfach ganz stumpf darüber
reden wie kohl eigentlich projekt
dancing aussieht unnormal krank kann man
darüber reden die gerne ich auch so
durch die lüfte segeln und wirbeln würde
also kurz und knapp mal schauen was in
der woche auch lange
ich glaube dass thommy de dieses video
wird unterstützt von klar breakdance ist
nicht nur ein tanzen oder ein
fahrgeschäft auf der kirmes es ist
vielmehr eine ganze kultur mit eigener
geschichte sprache und vor allem
tonnenweise mut begonnen hat alles in
new york der 60er jahre als djs
angefangen haben den teil des songs in
denen man nur den beat zu locken das ist
dann der sogenannte break da gerade dazu
einlädt ihnen mit tanz moves zu führen
dabei haben die breakdancer oder boys
und girls wie es eigentlich heißt
bewegungsabläufe mit den
unterschiedlichsten ursprüngen
miteinander verschmolzen darunter
kampfsportarten wie komfort aus china
oder cabrera welches eine art kampftanz
aus brasilien mit wurzeln in afrika aber
auch ein schlüssel vom stepptanz und
figuren aus den touren finden sich im
breakdance wieder das sind so unfassbar
schwierig auszuhalten die frage wo fange
ich eigentlich an die profi boys wird
von hier aber nicht einfach irgendwelche
wuchs zusammen in der geschichte des
breakdance in mehrere kategorien mit
verschiedenen bewegungen entstanden die
alle einen namen und etliche variationen
haben diese kategorien sind zum beispiel
frieses wie der sogenannte kick oder
power moves wie zb der erklärt wie ihr
euch jetzt denken könnt ist breakdance
tatsächlich eine sehr gefährliche
sportart bei der es häufig zu über
dehnungen prellungen oder sogar
knochenbrüchen kommen in der szene weiß
jeder bescheid dass jemand der so eine
performance abliefert dafür einen sehr
hohen preis gezahlt hat und zwar in der
währung schmerzt es gibt also tausende
tricks aber ich entscheide mich für
einen der power moves die sogenannte
windmill weil ich die vor fünf jahren
schon mal versucht habe aber es hat
nicht ganz geschafft habe und das ist
wirklich gerne ändern dieses video ist
schon seit über einem jahr geplant und
steht auf meiner video liste von einer
weile ist mit der youtuber mike schenk
jetzt tatsächlich zuvorgekommen mit dem
video breakdance lernen aber ich finde
es schlimm wenn sich zwei
selbstexperiment youtuber der gleichen
herausforderung stellen deswegen los
geht so ich suche mir mal tutorial aus
breakdance
tutorial und dann einfach das erstbeste
nimmt man und der sieht so aus als hätte
das drauf bisschen stretching ist das
peinlich ich hoffe ich muss das nicht
können da sind sie nicht alles
das klingt doch gar keine vorkenntnisse
das ist alles was man können muss es
generell gut kommt sein und einfach im
bergsprint zu können hat das natürlich
kommen sie ja gut dann nehme ich jetzt
einmal man in einfachen backspin klar
wieso brauchen drehungen sollten dann
schon drin sein
[Applaus]
hahaha ich gerne
hahahaha
[Musik]
dreht sich also actually aufsagen kreuz
hast du echt überraschender weise alles
extrem weh man fällt bei jedem hof und
immer irgendwie auf den hüften auf
seinen schultern oder sonst wohin es
klingt dumm ist mir gut und cool
aussehen habe ich glaub ich bestelle mir
dafür irgendwie kohle protektoren ich
suche also im netz nach schutzausrüstung
und schaue ob es da überhaupt etwas
motorradjacken die mir vorgeschlagen
werden eignet sich auf jeden fall schon
mal nicht ich finde eine hoffentlich
bewegliche hose und eine protektoren
jacke die dünn und ebenfalls beweglich
ist nur eins ist er definitiv nicht
günstig
ich mache den rest des tages immer
wieder kurze versuche aber durch das
ständige fallen auf die gleiche stelle
mit dem gesamten körpergewicht habe ich
jetzt schon krasse blaue flecken und
wenn ich das ganze hier eine woche
durchziehen möchte muss ich mich schon
also warte ich lieber bis die
protektoren ankommen
einmal eine ordentliche unterlage aber
hauptsächlich spannend finde ich
tatsächlich die protektoren
das ist zum beispiel die projektron hose
und hier nochmal einmal was hier oben
rum dass jetzt nicht die fans gefiel
also ich glaube damit soll es halbwegs
gehen ohne dass ich mit ihm also
tatsächlich mit der hüfte das und immer
noch weh aber am rücken natürlich nicht
mehr
[Musik]
das war schon mal
hoffentlich hat die ich so auch wirklich
eine ganze woche hartes training durch
wir finden es heraus ich befolge also
wieder das tutorial bevor man wechseln
macht dieses sinnvoll erst mal im topos
bild zu machen
[Musik]
wo gerade eine andere dimension gekickt
jetzt will ich nur noch den sprung
irgendwie in die luft kriegen
ja ich glaube dass ein ordentlicher
batzen erst geht's dir ich war mit dem
backspin
[Musik]
ich versuche nicht direkt volle kraft
voraus in die moves zu gehen sondern
langsam und kontrolliert einen schritt
nach dem anderen aus zu führen damit die
genaue abfolge der bewegung in fleisch
und blut übergeht trotzdem muss ich aber
spätestens alle 15 minuten pause machen
um wieder zu kraft zu kommen eines
meiner hauptprobleme ist es sich nach
dem hoch schwingen auf dem kreuz zu
bastian also übrig dass auch isoliert
[Musik]
okay du bist noch mal ohne dinge ich
glaube aber das ist natürlich
tut es weh ohne panzer
[Musik]
webtv dritten krieg diese pause jetzt
kommen anders der turn fries
ich bin
ich glaube das ist schon fast oder beim
sport beim abenteuer ganz allgemein aber
natürlich auch beim alltag besteht aber
immer der gefahr irgendwas kaputt zu
machen egal ob sich selbst
und irgendwas in seiner umgebung das
wird dann entweder ziemlich teuer oder
führt bei einer verletzung im
schlimmsten fall sogar zur
berufsunfähigkeit ob die wirte würden
sich gut versichert zu sein aber das ist
oft so kompliziert dass man überhaupt
keinen bock drauf hat und sich gar nicht
damit beschäftigt aber mit clark dem
sponsor des heutigen videos ändert sich
das clark ist ein digitaler
versicherungsmanager bei dem
vollautomatisch 160
versicherungsunternehmen miteinander
verglichen werden und die mit dem besten
preis-leistungs-verhältnis die wenn euch
präsentiert mit clark hast du kein
papierchaos mehr in unzähligen
aktenordnern sondern alles übersichtlich
in der app ich persönlich wusste ja bis
vor einem jahr noch nicht mal ob und
welche versicherungen ich überhaupt habe
und ich habe da geht es vielen von euch
ähnlich stark bietet ihr aber nicht nur
die möglichkeit neue versicherungen zu
top konditionen zu finden sondern auch
seine bestehenden versicherungen zu
überprüfen und der bessere angebote zu
machen wenn ihr euch jetzt über den link
in der beschreibung anmeldet könnt ihr
mit dem coach favre klagt sogar noch
einen amazon gutschein im wert von bis
zu 45 euro erhalten und alles was ihr
dafür machen müsst ist es drei
bestehende versicherungen in cloud
hochladen wo versicherungen gibt es in
15 euro ihr müsst dafür also noch nicht
mal eine neue versicherung abschließen
und selbst dann lohnt sich klagt einfach
nur für die bessere übersicht ich habe
gerade den gigantischen fehler gemacht
auf meinem rücken zu schauen
es ist nicht mehr normal oh mein gott
ich hab grad die aufnahme gesehen ist es
viel zu krass ich will nicht wissen wie
mein rücken dieser woche aussieht ich
gerade den baby fries bei dem ein
gesamtes gewicht auf eine hand
balanciert werden soll
[Musik]
dieses muster auf meinem rücken entsteht
übrigens durch meine protektoren die im
rückenteil luftlöcher haben obwohl das
ziemlich schlimm aussieht ist das immer
noch viel besser als ständig ungeschützt
auf die wirbelsäule zu donnern also will
ich mich auch heute wieder in den
lustigen schutzanzug und fange an mit
einigen den übungen die dehnbarkeit ist
übrigens neben der bloßen muskulatur und
der technik mit das wichtigste beim
breakdance nicht nur weil man sich sonst
sehr schnell verletzen kann sondern vor
allem gibt es sehr viele übungen die man
ohne große flexibilität gar nicht
schaffen kann da ich persönlich so
unbeweglich bin wird dadurch jede
bewegung für mich viel anstrengender und
deutlich unsauberer so mancher mit einem
ordentlichen text bin
[Musik]
ich dann schon nicht mit den anstieg
wurden ausschließlich gestern
[Musik]
und dann natürlich auch die babies
hier muss ich quasi aus dem baby face
auf meinen rücken fallen und hierbei ist
es extrem schwer seine hand so
einzubiegen dass ich nichts überdehnt
oder umknickt während das gesamte
körpergewicht quasi auf einer hand
lastet zwangsläufig tut das nach einiger
zeit in den schultern und auch im
handgelenk schon sehr weh aber so dumm
es klingt da muss ich jetzt einfach
durch
es heißt wer war ist es noch nicht mal
die hälfte davon abhält irgendwie fühlt
man sich schnell dabei ich schaue mir
das direkt an weil ich bin eigentlich
echt gespannt wie das so aussieht
ich finde es schon ganz okay
also ohne witz ich meine dass ich noch
nicht viel ich weiß aber dass zum ersten
mal so richtig irgendwie hoffen dass uns
das werden könnte
[Musik]
der übergang von beatrice auf meinem
rücken und das drehen mit den beiden
klappt schon ganz gut aber es hat extrem
lange gedauert bis sich die einzelnen
bewegungen verinnerlicht habe obwohl es
nur eine super kurze abfolge ist die
drehung um die horizontale achse passt
so weit jetzt versuche ich mehr schwung
in die vertikale drehung zu bekommen
erst schaffte ich eine viertel umdrehung
dann durch mir weh und hier schaffe ich
bereits eine halbe umdrehung in diese
rückenlage zu kommen ist aber nur die
halbe miete ist der nächste schritt ist
es nämlich sich mit seinen armen
aufzuraffen um wieder zum baby fuß zu
kommen um dann das ganze erneut zu
machen und hier habe ich sogar eine drei
viertel umdrehung geschafft das alles
muss aber natürlich noch deutlich
schneller und vor allem flüssiger
ablaufen
[Musik]
aber so richtig will auch nicht dass
ich meine beide immer fest angespannt
und auseinander
[Musik]
letzter lauf der 1
ich werde jeden tag ein stück besser und
besser aber die geschwindigkeit in der
ich fortschritte machte war am anfang am
größten und nahm mit der zeit immer
weiter ab auch wenn es in der mitte
meines experiments noch so aussah als
könnte die windmühle in einer woche
möglich sein ausgehend von dem tempo mit
dem ich mich in den ersten drei tagen
verbessert habe dauern die einzelnen
meilensteine und durchbrüche am ende der
woche so lange dass ich noch bestimmten
den ganzen monat brauchen würde um
flüssig durch die luft wirbeln zu können
und um so eleganz dabei aus zu sehen
wohl mindestens ein ja ich bin viel
beweglicher geworden durch die dehnung
wenn jeden tag sie mal auf jeden fall
schon unterschied zum anfang auch wenn
es echt noch immer schlecht ist ich fand
es auch richtig glaube ich die
bewegungen die ich am anfang noch
überhaupt nicht richtig nachvollziehen
konnte stück für stück und muskel für
muskel rücken mehr verinnerlicht habe
wenn ich mich am anfang noch richtig zum
training zwingen musste weil immer alles
will getan hat für jeden einzelnen in
chrom nachdenken musste machte richtig
spaß und wenn ich dran vorbei gemacht
dass ich denke ich mir so hey jetzt mal
so ein knochen brechen der move hätte
ich eigentlich voll bock drauf ist und
mittlerweile sind meine ganzen schultern
und meine hüften und meinen rücken auch
einfach ein einzelner blauer fleck das
tun auch nicht weniger wie habe ich habe
mich einfach den schmerz gewöhnt
letztendlich war die windmühle in einer
woche ein viel zu großes ziel aber wenn
man sich immer nur ziel gesetzt von
denen man vorher schon weiß dass man sie
schafft dann wäre es leben auch glaube
ich ziemlich langweilig belegen zur
versicherung sap clark ist eine video
beschreibung sichert euch da gerne bis
zu 45 euro amazon guthaben wenn auch
diese art von videos in denen ich etwas
lernen tester oder irgendein anderes
verrücktes experiment angehe ja wenn
euch das gefällt abonniert hier gern
schreibt auch gern ein kommentar und
dann sieht man am nächsten wieder
macht's gut
[Musik]
noch